Here's an example of the need for barriers.
Say we've got an array in memory with a bunch of elements: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6,
and we want to shift each of these left by 1.
In other words, we want this element go here,
this element go here, this element go here and so on.
So here's a little code snippet that should do this.
We first initialize the elements of array to the thread index,
and you'll see that I've hardcoded of this to 128 just to be lazy.
So every thread is going to set its corresponding array element to its own index.
So this should initialize things to 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6 and so on.
And then avoiding stepping off the end of the array with this if statement,
every thread will set its corresponding array element
at its index equal to the value of the array element at the thread's index plus 1.
So thread 1 will set its value to whatever is written in array sub 2.
Thread 2 will set array sub 2 equal to whatever is in array sub 3 and so forth.
So here's a quick quiz: How many barriers does this code need?